(electronic sound)
- School, sports, looks, accomplishments,
people aren't reverse engineering
their kids for happiness.
They're engineering them
to make them look good.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- Parents, stop fucking up.
On some real shit, fuck you.
You should not be using your kids
as a tool to make you look good.
(instrumental music)
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(slow piano)
Super excited about today's podcast.
I have Allen Robinson, superstar
wide receiver for Chicago Bears,
former Jacksonville Jaguar.
Why don't you tell the Vayner Nation
a little bit just about
yourself in a whole,
about someone who's just meeting you,
they're like, "Yo, what's good?
"Who are you?"
- Yeah, so for me,
growing up born and raised
in Detroit, Michigan, I think, again
now that I'm in Chicago,
you know, it's very similar.
So a lot of things as far as me growing up
I can just kinda relate to as far as
city-wise, things like that, you know.
And also, even going to Penn State.
I give a lot of respect to
Detroit and to my parents,
because that kinda molded me to be
everything and where I'm at today,
even as far as knowing how
to get through adversity,
knowing the value of
just having a work ethic.
You know, I think that's
something that's very,
like, not understood for a lot of people.
People are given a lot of things.
Even when it comes to me and just kind of
being able to, you know what I'm saying,
dig back into different situations
and relate different
situations in my life.
I can kinda attest to things
that when I was younger,
you know things that my dad
told me, things that was
instilled in me from-
- [Gary] Give me something.
Give me something.
I love that, and that's what
I love about it as you know.
So like, give me a straight-up
story, right off the bat
of something that you
either did that was good,
bad, or different, or
something did something bad,
good, or different to you and Pop said-
- I would say a thing
that really sticks to me
in high school is, for me-
- [Gary] So you're in high school.
- I'm in high school.
- [Gary] How good of an
athlete are you at that point?
- At that point in time, I'd probably say
I'm a decent athlete.
- [Gary] What year are you?
- I'm kind of smaller.
This is my freshman year.
Actually, I would say
going into high school.
- [Gary] Eighth grade, yeah.
- From going from the
eighth grade to the ninth grade.
I wanted to go to the
public school, you know,
that was around my area.
- [Gary] 'Cause your friends were there.
- Because my friends were going there.
A lot of the coaches, they knew me.
They had watched me play Little League
and stuff like that growing up, you know.
But again, in middle school
I wasn't the best student.
You know, I would get in trouble.
(Gary laughs)
Doing stupid stuff.
- [Gary] Dumb shit?
- Getting suspended from school.
(Gary laughs)
You know what I'm sayin'?
Like, the normal like stuff.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So my parents, they
wanted to send me away.
- Paint a picture for me,
how rough or not rough,
like in the scale of like one is,
- [Allen] Yeah.
- Rough shit, to like 10
is like Beverly Hills.
Where does your neighborhood
that you grew up in?
- Yeah, so I grew up actually in Detroit.
Then we actually moved to Southfield.
So I would probably say I went from like
a two to three to like a five.
- [Gary] Okay.
- But again, even in that situation,
I'll kinda dive into
that a little bit later,
but you know, going back
from eighth to ninth grade,
for me, I wanted to go
to the public school.
That's where everybody
who was familiar with me,
I was familiar with everybody, you know.
But my parents wanted me
to get away from that.
And they wanted me to get away from that
to have a different experience, you know.
Because they saw, in their eyes,
they saw where they thought
I was headed, you know.
- [Gary] And was that professionally
from a sports standpoint?
- Not, it was just.
- [Gary] I have the
privilege of knowing you.
They just knew you had
something, as a person.
- Yeah, they just didn't want
me to go down the wrong road.
Getting caught up in
stuff with my friends,
and stuff like that.
So they sent me to a private school,
all boys private school at that.
- [Gary] And were you just like dead?
- I was devastated.
- Like when they really finally laid down,
they're like, "you're going."
When probably Pops looked at
you and said, "you're going."
Did you literally, I'm trying
to think of your age group,
did you go, like, on AOL,
or like did you go outside
and be like, "yo fuck."
- [Gary] Yes, exactly.
- Yeah.
- That's exactly what it was.
- I know that's what you did.
You went to your three best friends,
said "this is some bullshit."
- 'Cause they had like, 7-on-7s and stuff.
- [Gary] Right.
- Definitely.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I mean, for me, I didn't know
nobody who was going out there.
It probably is like an
hour and some change away
from like, where I lived.
- Did that school have good diversity
'cause they had good sports?
Or was it a bunch of white kids?
- A little bit of both.
- [Gary] Okay.
- The sports had diversity.
But actually.
- [Gary] The rest
of the school didn't. Cliche.
- Kinda even.
- [Gary] No really right?
Good prep school wants
to be good at sports.
- Exactly.
- [Gary] Bring in the athletes,
of course yeah, America.
- Fresh prince.
(laughs and claps)
I love that.
- That's exactly what it was.
- [Gary] Did you like think
of yourself as fresh prince?
- For sure, especially
once I was like a senior.
- [Gary] Yeah, and you are
cute so I can see how you
could pull that off.
(Allen laughs)
I get it, go ahead.
- So, you know, so then you would throw
all that in the mix.
And this is probably halfway
through my eighth grade year.
- [Gary] Half through eighth grade year
when they told you this is locked?
- Or this is like the play,
this is in motion.
- Did they give it to you hard,
like those kind of parents?
Or did they, did mom like
subtly start hinting.
- [Allen] Subtly, subtly, you know.
- [Gary] They had a strategy.
- You could take visits,
you know what I'm saying.
So I took, I missed my
own day at regular school
to take a visit to this school.
You know what I'm saying?
- You're like "this is corny, fuck this."
(Gary laughs)
- The most boring thing
I've ever been a part of in my life.
I'm like, I did not want to go here.
- So you went through, got in the car,
like "mom, I'm not going."
- Yes, that's exactly it,
literally.
(Gary laughs)
Exactly how it was.
So then you go a little
bit, me and my dad,
they had like a 7-on-7, you know.
Kind of like, in the spring.
So my dad took me out there.
I didn't get out of the car.
I told him I wasn't going there,
- [Gary] Hmm.
- So, the long story short,
I had a conversation with one of my,
in the eighth grade,
with one of the teachers.
And he's like, you know,
everyone raise their hand
who's going to Southfield High School,
that's like the public school.
Then there's like another
school that's like across town,
you know what I'm saying,
raise your hand if you're
going to this school.
I didn't raise my hand for neither.
And I just was that kid.
So he's like, so where
are you going to school?
You know what I'm saying?
I was like, "I'm going to Orchard Lake."
And he's like, "no you're not."
You can't get into Orchard Lake,
you know what I'm saying?
That kind of vibe.
And from that moment, it switched.
- Interesting.
- It switched, from that
moment forward, it switched.
- [Gary] No.
- Yup.
- God I fuck with that
story, that's who I am.
When somebody said you couldn't,
it made it interesting.
- Yep, I'll never forget that.
That was like the moment,
and I was like okay cool,
like I'm with it.
I'll accept the fact that my
parents want me to go there.
I'ma go here.
- Just to stick it to
Mr. Jones in science.
- For sure, for sure, and
again that's kind of where
it was at for me.
- And what happened?
Now I'm really into this story.
Do you love it in September
when you get there?
Is it instant love?
Do you have it the first three
months and then it got good?
- I hated the first year.
- [Gary] Did some senior
girl start liking you?
And you're like, "oh,
okay, wait a minute."
- I hated the first year.
- [Gary] Full year?
- Yup. So for me, I'm
playing freshman football.
I'm small, I play running back
and cornerback at this time.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I'm still a pretty good player,
but going to any other
school besides that one,
I wasn't gonna play freshman.
- [Gary] You were not.
- So I'm playing freshman.
It's frustrating.
- You wouldn't have played?
- I would've played either JV or Varsity.
- Got it, so their school
team was that good.
- Yeah they were good, I'm
not gonna lie, they were good,
especially on varsity, but still.
- [Gary] At the time,
you're like fuck this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] Okay, in hindsight,
now that you're a super star
football player, you can say that.
- Yeah, so I'm like telling my dad.
- [Gary] You think, you didn't
have your growth spurt yet?
- No I probably was like 5'8" at the time.
- And then, how did it go?
You're a freshman.
- Then fast forward to basketball season.
I'm on freshman basketball.
And I tell my dad, I'm like, I'm like,
I'm leaving this school.
This is ridiculous.
- [Gary] I hate it academically,
'cause it's probably harder, fuck that.
- Grades get all crazy.
I'm on freshman football,
freshman basketball.
- What about socially?
- Socially it was different.
I still kind of had my culture
of people who kinda came
from the city as well.
We all kinda in the same mindset.
- [Gary] Of course.
- We all come from the city,
we don't want to be here.
- I see, day one,
you're looking around
like I got you, I got you.
- Yeah, we're all kind
of on the same page,
like our parents got us out here.
(Gary laughs)
It is what it is.
The school used to send a bus to the city
to pick us all up at like
6 o'clock in the morning.
- So they were your homies.
- Yeah, so we all used to
take the bus in the morning,
every morning like "we hate this."
Why are our parents sending us out here?
We all just want to go to
our neighborhood schools.
Like, so, then, fast
forward to basketball,
I'm on freshman coming
off the bench out there.
(Gary laughs)
I'm like, I'm like.
- [Gary] You hate life.
- It's the worst.
(Gary laughs)
I think the first five to six games.
- I'm sorry to interrupt you.
Just knowing how successful
you've been at the NFL level,
I'm so happy right now.
So much of what I do is
for the 14-year-old me.
I had nobody to look up to.
There was no entrepreneurship.
- [Gary] Mhmm.
- There was no cool entrepreneurship.
There wasn't even entrepreneurship.
I'm just so happy right now,
'cause I know right this second.
Whether it's right this
second or in four weeks
when somebody sees this,
there's like a 15 year old
that just now gets to use this comp.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I'm on the bench in basketball.
- And I think it's over,
but wait a minute, what?
Let me keep listening, go ahead.
- So, first, I think first
game, first six games,
I had come off the bench.
I take that back.
First two games I came off the bench.
I came off the bench, first game I had 18.
Came off the bench off the second game,
I had like 26.
- [Gary] You went crazy.
- So now I'm starting.
Next game I have like 25,
next game 26, next game like 28.
Next game 30.
- [Gary] So you're balling.
- Halfway through the season,
I'm on JV.
Mind you, I started off
freshman on the bench.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- So then I get moved up to JV.
Then I do the same
thing on JV pretty much.
Then like the coach comes to me,
he's like look, I didn't want to start you
to mess up the chemistry.
'Cause we already had
our starting point guard and everything.
But then we had like our league playoffs,
even though it was JV.
I started for the playoffs.
- [Gary] Wow.
- We ended up losing the first game.
But now things are kind of
starting to change a little bit.
- 'Cause you're getting
some clout in school?
- Yeah.
(Gary laughs)
It's more of a, yeah.
- [Gary] (unintelligible) good.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] It's flowing.
- And again, it was very competitive
from a sports standpoint.
'Cause you got a lot of kids
coming from all different
places to come to this
school to play sports.
So there was also two freshmen
who came in the same year
as me who played varsity.
- Wow.
- They ended up transferring
their sophomore year.
- [Gary] Really?
- Yup, both of them ended up
transferring as sophomores.
- Did either one of them go on
to have good college or pro careers?
- No they did not.
I think one of them, he
ended up playing in college.
But I don't think
for any big school.
- [Gary] I got you, go ahead.
- So then, shot out to my
boy Joan, Woody, and CJ,
'cause they both were my guys.
They both ended up transferring
their sophomore year.
And then, that's kind of when, now.
- It opened up for you.
- Everything started
to just kind of change,
you know what I'm saying?
'Cause I kind of was the
guy who was the grinder,
you know what I'm saying?
They came in, they played
varsity, you know what I'm saying?
- They had the fucking clout,
they had the height.
- Yeah, but everything just
kind of started to change.
Then going into my sophomore year,
I'm like 6'1.5" now.
- [Gary] Hmm.
- So I go from 5'8" to 6'1".
You know.
- [Gary] Five inches matter.
(group laughs)
- Everything starts to change.
I end up playing varsity.
I started off the year
on JV my sophomore year.
- [Gary] Football.
- I actually didn't play
football 'cause I was hurt
from growth spurts.
Like I couldn't do nothing,
my body was just like sore.
Like for real, so I didn't play football
my sophomore year.
- Hold on, Allen Robinson,
who you are right this second,
did not play sophomore year?
- [Allen] Nope.
- On some, my body hurts.
- Yeah, I couldn't run.
(laughs)
I couldn't run, I couldn't do nothing.
- Right 'cause you change
and all of a sudden
you're not a running back's body.
- Exactly, my whole body has changed.
So I go from like 5'7",
5'8" to like 6'1.5" 6'2".
So my whole body has like changed.
I'm progressively getting better,
but like over the summer, I couldn't do
summer workouts and stuff.
So by the time November, December hit,
I'm feeling good, I'm
ready to play basketball.
So then, I play basketball.
I start off on JV.
Those dudes kind of transfer
throughout the course of the year.
It's a lot of stuff.
They're missing games.
It's a lot going on.
My school's literally like the NBA
when it comes to dudes
who're like, "I don't
"want to be here."
You know what I'm saying?
You got dudes that are like
not coming to practice.
- Just real shit.
- They're going through
like a transfer process.
They're looking at
other schools and stuff.
So long story short,
they end up transferring.
I get moved up to varsity
end of my sophomore year.
And then, in the following year,
now I'm on varsity, I'm 6'3".
Everything's like.
- [Gary] Locked.
- Yeah.
- Junior year football, what happens?
- I have a good year.
- [Gary] Wide receiver?
- I play receiver.
I play receiver and corner.
- So you were corner and running back.
Prior to that, could you always catch?
- I could always catch.
I remember having a
conversation with my dad
after hitting the growth spurt.
That like, 'cause I didn't
play my sophomore year.
So then that whole
spring after basketball,
was like, you're about to like, receiver.
I'm like damn, I've played
running back my whole life.
I don't know how it really is
to play receiver, you know.
- Any advantages from playing
running back to receiver?
- Oh, a ton.
How you just see the
field and the movements
and stuff is different.
Even when you catch the ball
and how you press blocks.
- So one of the things that's crazy,
and obviously I quadrupled
down once you signed with us.
Watching you, like, do you,
I'm about to give you a
huge compliment, you know,
in comparison to all the
Jet receivers I've watched
through the years,
your separation sometimes
feels uncomfortable.
Do you think that's running back shit?
- [Allen] For sure, for sure.
- 'Cause you really just got it.
- Being able to move,
even when you catch
the ball and are seeing
different angles and things like that,
it's all, I would attest,
to being a running back.
I played running back my whole life
up until my junior year in high school.
So then, I played receiver my junior year,
senior year, freshman year in college,
sophomore year, junior year in college.
Before I got to the NFL,
that was the only time
I played receiver, was
like, those five years.
- When did it click, receiver?
(Allen sighs)
- I would probably say
going into my senior year.
- During that spring and summer?
- Yeah, during that spring it clicked.
I would say basketball too, both.
- Did you think as a freshman or sophomore
you were going to be a basketball player?
- For sure, me and one
of my high school coaches
used to have a bet, used
to tell me your first offer
is gonna come from, from
like your first big offer's
gonna come from football
before basketball.
We were always going
back and forth with it.
And like, going into my
senior year, my junior year,
I'm literally taking a nap.
He like, texts me a number.
He's like, "yo, call this number."
So I call the number,
they answer the phone.
It's the Minnesota coaching staff.
And that was my first offer.
Actually my first offer
was a Big Ten offer.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- So after that, everything just changed.
It got real, because my parents,
and shout out to my parents 'cause
throughout the whole process,
like my mom, still at my house right now,
has like a whole thick book of everybody
that like sent me letters,
the places, the schools
that I wanted to go to,
sending out questionnaires.
Us sending out highlight
tapes, things like that.
Sending them to different
schools and stuff.
My parents definitely
were heavily involved.
- Were your parents athletes?
- They were not, they were not.
I just think that, for
my parents, you know,
from five years old, I had been,
probably even before that, one of the most
competitive kids in sports,
that like, you probably could,
- Did you cry when you lost?
- Of course.
- I cried basically until I was like 12
if I lost at anything.
I was also so confident I was delusional.
- [Allen] Same.
- I cried 'cause I was
stunned I didn't win.
- Same, same.
I remember, it used to be so bad.
And my dad was like look.
You win a lot of games.
- [Gary] Stop crying.
- Yeah like you win a lot of games.
(laughs)
I always tell people,
you know, having kids,
and like having, I don't
know how I would want
to introduce sports to my kids.
- Well there's a huge different variable.
When I was doing a wine
show on the internet
back in the day, I had Wayne Gretzky
on 'cause he had a wine,
which is super cool, greatest
hockey player of all time.
And, super funny story, there is people
before we got on set, were
like Wayne's very introverted.
He's not going to say what's up.
It's not bad, just don't worry about him.
I'm like cool.
Of course I'm thinking I'm
the most charismatic fucker
on earth, we're gonna be
best friends in two minutes.
Sure enough, just one little opening,
and I didn't know this.
I didn't know this, 'cause
I don't do homework.
I mention that I was from Belarus,
he's like, "my
grandfather's from Belarus."
Which is cool, 'cause I didn't know,
and like the greatest hockey player
having Russian descent makes sense.
We got into a conversation then
'cause there was something
wrong with a camera actually.
Somehow we got into him saying
that he wouldn't let his kids play hockey.
And I thought it was super fresh.
And that's, with your story.
Same with me as an entrepreneur,
I think every day about
my daughter and son.
I'm like, I'm not gonna pressure them
to be an entrepreneur
and I'm not even sure
I want them to be, because
you know what happens.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- It's gonna be comparison city.
Now, in baseball, we have
a whole wave right now
of kids who are coming
up who are the juniors.
- [Allen] Yeah, yeah.
- Vlad, Tatis, Biggio, Bichette, I mean,
it's crazy in baseball right now.
We see in football,
right, you know the Bosas.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- You see it.
It's an interesting conversation of like,
do you want your child to do it
when they have to look up to something?
- [Allen] Yeah.
- You're gonna have some
real all-time success.
- For sure, I mean for
me, honestly, I wouldn't,
I'm kind of selfish in that sense,
I tell people all the time,
you know what I'm saying,
when I have a son I want
him to play quarterback.
I tell everybody that.
You know.
- You wanna make him the player you wish
threw to you your whole life?
- Yeah, that's kind of the selfish me.
But I think in general in sports,
I would love for him
to want to play sports.
I think sports molded me
in a lot of different ways.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Gary] Of course.
- It taught me how to
go through adversity.
It taught me the value of a worth ethic,
you know what I'm saying?
It taught me the value
of perfecting a craft
in the sense of just learning a craft
and wanting to perfect it.
- On craft, for everybody's
who's listening.
By the way if you're listening,
we're about to get to calls.
Put in your phone number on Facebook,
especially if you're a Bears,
Penn State, and Jags fan.
I want to give you that.
Or if you're listening, adversity mindset,
high school life.
Allen, how much, and I
think this confuses people,
how much film work have
you done in your career?
How much film?
- [Allen] A lot.
- Tell the averages out there.
I think they just don't realize
how much studying you fuckers do.
- Yeah, a lot, that's the thing.
Most of our days is watching film.
If you look at even like now.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- We come into the facility.
We're in a facility 10 to 11 hours a day.
I would probably say.
- Do you like film work or do you hate it?
- I do.
Yeah I like it.
- And are you like straight
up looking for like,
oh this dude on this Lions, he has a tick.
- [Allen] For sure.
- You're looking for the subtlest shit.
- When you're watching defenses, you know,
watching tendencies,
watching players' weaknesses.
Also, for me, I'm big on,
I like watching other receivers.
You know, right now, even in my iPad,
over this next month before
I get some OTA time off,
watch all of Amari Cooper's targets.
Watch all of Keenan Allen's targets.
Just guys who are.
- Big shout out to Keenan Allen
when he was coming out of Cal,
I wanted the Jets to take
him in the first round.
All my friends were making fun of me.
He slipped to the third round I believe.
- [Allen] Yup, he's a beast.
- He's had an iconic career.
- [Allen] He's a beast.
- And if I was the Jets owner
we would have gotten the benefit of that.
Anyway, nonetheless Allen.
- Yeah, so just watching
guys like Michael Thomas,
Julio Jones, you know.
'Cause you see these dudes, who are
you know what I'm saying,
very good receivers.
- On that note, pregame
workout, post game daps,
are you the guy that talks
to guys before the game?
Are you the guy that talks
to people after the game?
Or you talk to nobody never ever?
How do you roll?
- After the game for sure.
Before game it just depends.
It depends on.
- If you went to college with them
and they're your boy?
- It's tough to say.
- Would you go up to,
like, you play the Falcons next year,
will you go up to Julio.
If you're both running there early.
- [Allen] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Early, would you be
like, "yo, good year."
"Hope you're doing well."
- [Allen] For sure.
- Stay well, stay healthy fam.
Like that kind of shit?
- Definitely.
'Cause again.
- 'Cause you're competitive.
- [Allen] For sure.
- So I'm like.
- But see this is the
thing about football,
personally, personally I'm competitive.
But me personally, I'm not
going up against Julio.
- [Gary] I agree.
- You know what I'm saying.
- [Gary] It's more about
like fuck the Falcons.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I agree with that.
- I've always wondered.
- Now corner back wise.
- Corner?
- Nah, nah, nah, I'm real
cool with Darius Slay.
We play against each other all the time.
Shout out to Darius.
- Darius, I know you're about to get paid,
so good for you.
But bro, Allen got you last year.
(Allen laughs)
That's the play I was
referencing on separation, bro.
- So like Slay, I won't
talk to him before the game,
you know what I'm saying.
- [Gary] After the game?
- After the game, all love, yeah.
You know what I'm saying, that's my boy.
You know what I'm saying?
We came out a year apart.
We started off in the same agency,
you know what I'm saying.
So just over time.
- What about, what about,
who's in the league that
you went to school with?
- Adrian Amos.
- Oh I love that.
- Did not talk to him before the game.
That's my boy, you know what I'm saying.
- [Gary] But after the
game it's fine right.
- Yeah, for sure.
- What about the week ahead?
Like when you're playing Slay?
Like when you text him on
Wednesday like boy I got you.
- [Allen] No, no, no.
- Okay, none of that shit.
- I don't get too caught up into that.
I'm really, when it comes
to like, during the season,
I'm really like.
- [Gary] Quiet.
- Probably the most quiet
and like boring person.
- Good, I know that.
Bro I don't even hit you
up during the season.
- During the season I don't do anything.
- Literally, you know, I
don't even talk to you.
I know you're in you're cocoon.
- Yeah, that's what it is.
That's really what it is,
being literally in a cocoon.
'Cause that's the thing, your days are
seven to seven, pretty much.
- I get it, you got numbers?
Let's get one in real quick.
This is fun Allen.
I get that cocoon shit, man.
My big thing, I used to
think that I wouldn't dap
after the game, 'cause
I was such a sore sport.
I used to spit on my hand.
Literally, cry and leave.
As I get older I'm like oh,
I'm competitive on the field.
But after I'm like how's your mother.
- [Allen] For sure.
- I'm a human, and I've seen
that myself in business.
I'm a human to my competitors in business.
- And that's the thing.
You respect your competitors.
- [Gary] That's for
sure, I respect anybody
going for it, for real.
- [Jared] Hello.
- [Gary] Jared, it's Gary
Vaynerchuk and Allen Robinson.
- Yo, what's good Jared?
- [Jared] No way, oh my
goodness, this is life-changing.
I've entered probably 150,000 of these
and it's never worked.
But God told me to do it this morning.
- Let's go God!
Good shit God.
- [Jared] Thanks to God, or
intuition or whatever it is,
Gary you're magic, you're a magical man
so you never know with you.
- Thank you brother.
Where are you from and
what's your question?
- So I'm from Colorado and Las Vegas.
I'm 21 years old.
I spent about 10 to 12 years in the bowl.
Mostly from Colorado and the
Grand Junction, Aspen area.
And I'm a musician and I
played football for nine years.
And you know, this is
probably the only opportunity
I'm gonna get on this.
One day, I'm also gonna say,
and Allen I'm gonna meet you too
now that we've, you know,
had this phone conversation.
- Definitely.
- I'm gonna meet you, and I'm gonna change
the music industry and
the world for the better.
- Let me give you a sneak peek.
I think the Jets play
the Bears in two years.
So when that schedule comes out,
you should definitely take a look.
Now that we might be
going to 17-game schedule,
my ability to know who the
Jets play nine years out
is changing a little bit.
(Allen laughs)
But that's gonna be your hat bro.
You can meet me and Allen on the same day.
- [Gary] That's what I was gonna say,
I don't care how much games I gotta go to.
I'm gonna meet you guys.
- Awesome.
- [Allen] Definitely.
- [Jared] I'm moving actually to LA
in the next month actually.
April 2nd is when I've got
planned to move out there.
- Good for you.
- I'm gonna be doing
stand up comedy and music,
and I'm gonna be trying to
become the biggest thing
in the whole entire world.
(laughs)
So hopefully I can get
on to y'all's level,
and then we can meet and be buddies.
- Bro, we can meet,
we can meet and be buddies
before you get to that level.
- [Jared] Do whatever it
takes, I don't care Gary.
You've changed my life with motivation.
- [Allen] That's what's up.
- [Jared] I've listened to hours of you.
I'm gonna be at your funeral.
- Thank you.
I'll explain later.
- [Jared] Watching you on
the field, the motivation.
- If you don't have the
context, it's like what.
- [Allen] I appreciate it.
- Thank you so much brother.
Do you have a quick question,
or are you just fired up?
'Cause I like fired up.
- Oh, I'm fired up that
I'm talking to my hero
right now Gary V.
The question is, where do you guys see
the league going for one?
- That's a good question.
- [Caller] I feel like
the league went through
weird, political changes.
- Yup, yup.
- [Caller] Mainstream
changes the way social media,
so in the next five to 10,
where do you see it going?
I'm a huge lover of the game,
where do we see it going?
- Great question, we're gonna
drop you off in a second.
But as a huge lover of the game,
are you a Broncos fan?
- Aw man, it's hard being
a Broncos fan right now.
You know, I'm from, I have a
lot of family from Illinois,
and I was born there.
I'm from like, I lived there
when I was one through three.
- So you're a Bears fan?
- Yeah, I'm actually a huge Bears fan.
- Shout out to the Bears.
- [Caller] The Bears, I have
to be a Raiders fan now though.
- Bro, this is very important to me.
You need to save up some money
and buy an Allen Bears jersey.
- Promise you, Gary.
I will send you a DM and Facebook
with the Allen Bears jersey I will buy.
- Do me a favor 'cause I want to see it.
The number one place, it's
good for everybody to know,
the number one place
that is most guaranteed
for me to see it is Twitter.
Like if you use @garyvee,
I just see a lot in that feed.
And 1-2-1-2-9-3-1-5-7-3-1,
my text platform,
I see a lot of DM, I'm
just getting 10,000 a day.
It's just, it's impossible.
- [Jared] Right.
- Thank you brother, have a great day.
I'm glad you got through.
Allen, where do you
think the league's going
next five to 10 years?
I set up this podcast
with your thoughtfulness.
What's an interesting hot
take or random thought
that you have that maybe others don't see?
- Not anything too crazy.
- Nothing too crazy?
Can I give you a crazy
one before I let you go?
I have this weird thought
that in 20 or 30 years,
the NFL might play without helmets.
- I can see that,
I can see like the soft
helmets like on 7-on-7.
- You know, it's interesting, I've been
thinking a lot about like,
helmets are a problem
because people don't
know their faces, right?
NBA players, we hear a lot of,
I've talked to a lot of football players
like, "fucking helmets."
You know this, you're wearing the AR,
but this is real, a
lot of football players
wear big ass chains with numbers on them
because they know subconsciously,
they know nobody knows who they are.
And fuck, if you're a
fucking super star like that
at that level, you want to.
- [Allen] Yeah, for sure.
- You know, and so, there's that.
And the concussions, what would happen
if big dudes like that.
Like rugby, everyone's like
Gary they're too big and fast.
I'm like, you watch rugby?
Those rugby fuckers.
- [Allen] Yeah they get after it.
- They get after it in New
Zealand and South Africa
and those places.
Because they know they don't have helmets,
they don't have as much shit go down.
You have a helmet, you
fucking go in like a missile.
I think my weird hot take
is 25 years from now,
NFL no helmets.
- I can see that.
I can see that.
I also think that the whole,
I think the fantasy football
has helped out the
whole like facial thing.
- [Gary] Yeah I agree.
- I think that people playing fantasy.
- You play fantasy?
- [Allen] I do not play fantasy?
- Did you ever consider it?
Have you ever?
- No I never have.
- [Gary] Too weird?
- I actually kind of
wanted to play basketball.
But I don't know, just the whole like.
- Has anybody in the
league ever come up to you
and been like, "yo,
have a good game today.
"I got you on my fantasy team."
- Some people yeah.
- That's crazy, I love that shit.
- I think that helped out a lot.
- The whole sports card thing that I've
been telling you about,
I've been thinking about it.
I'm like, man, in 24 months,
'cause basketball cards
are going through the roof.
Some of these guys are
gonna like make jokes,
like drop 30 tonight.
I bought 100 of your rookies last night.
- I could believe it.
- [Gary] 100%, 100%.
You know, now with the
gambling and things like that,
you know, everybody, the whole
fantasy thing is going crazy.
I probably say.
- Fans are yelling at you.
- 80% of people who I ever encounter.
- [Gary] Bring that up.
- Yeah bring fantasy up.
- Yeah, you're on the road.
You think it's a hostile
environment in Minnesota,
and Minnesota fans are like,
"Allen, have a good game.
"I got you in fantasy."
- That's the exact,
that's the exact point.
- That's where I get fucking pissed.
I get crazy on that shit as a real fan.
Like, when my crew of Jet
fans, like quietly claps.
I'll never forget this,
my bro, Alex Cline,
fucking clapped for AJ Green on a play
against the Jets on a Jets-Bangles game,
I lost my mind.
I'm like, "we're fucking Jets fans."
Fuck your fantasy team, bench his ass.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- I don't give a shit if you know
we have a soft secondary.
- Yeah that's how it goes though,
that's really how it goes.
- Yeah man.
- Everybody, you could be
on the road everywhere.
- That's why everyone sucks.
Fucks all of you people.
(Allen laughs)
Let's put another number
in, I'm getting pissed.
If you're a fucking Vikings fan,
you can't like Allen.
It's a rule.
- You know, there's some
Vikings fans that you'll see,
I got you on fantasy.
- Have a big game, but I hope you lose.
- That's probably the best feeling.
That's the best feeling as a player,
that's the best feeling as a player
in a hostile environment.
- [Caller] Hello?
Yes?
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk and Allen Robinson.
- [Caller] I'm not
believing this right now.
- It's happening bro, where you from?
- [Caller] I'm from, I'm
in Knoxville, Tennessee.
- Love Knoxville.
- [Caller] I'm from Nashville.
- I get it, I know Knoxville.
- [Caller] You know Knoxville, okay.
- Of course.
- I remember you had your one place,
was it line or marketing in Chattanooga?
- That's exactly right.
So, I know Tennessee quite
well for that reason.
- [Caller] Yeah, Chattanooga.
- Yup, thank you bro.
What's your question?
- [Caller] I just heard
Allen talking about
how he was also really
passionate about basketball
at one time, in high school playing both,
and seeing like a future in basketball.
And I was just curious,
I know a lot of athletes
are better at one sport.
People push them towards one sport more,
but they may like the other sport better.
I had a friend like that in high school
who went to go play in Miami,
just because he could play
football and basketball
at the same time.
That was like very important to him.
- Understood.
- [Caller] So I was just curious about,
kind of the same thing
for entrepreneurship,
you lean into what
everybody's pushing towards,
or what they could be better at.
- Or where you think the money is.
- [Caller] Or what you're
more passionate about.
- That's a great question.
Allen, did you, how did you
personally think about that?
You loved basketball.
- To this day, I love basketball.
- I know, I watched you last night.
- To be honest, I'll watch.
- A basketball game over a football game
any day of the week.
- For sure, for sure.
When it gets around playoff
time it's kinda different,
you know what I'm saying.
I'm like actually immersed in the NFL.
- [Gary] Of course.
- After playing in the
playoffs and things like that.
Yeah, so, but for me, basketball
I would probably say was pushed more.
- How much did you,
- [Allen] 100 times.
- Debate not, when you
went, so what happened?
What was your most
serious basketball offer?
- My high school coach
told me I could've gone
to Michigan State and played both.
There actually was a guy named Dion Sims,
shout out to Dion, who I
played in Chicago with as well,
he went to my high school,
he went to Michigan State.
He played both.
You know, so.
- So what made you go to Penn State?
- I wanted to play football.
- At that point in your life.
- Going to my senior year, I had decided.
I said I was gonna play
football in college.
- [Gary] Because?
- Honestly, honestly.
- This is actually a great
question that he's asking.
I have a feeling you're
about to answer this,
this is a good moment: why?
- Football was just, it was easier.
Not easier in the sense
like, it was easier to do.
- [Gary] You were better at it.
But for me on the field.
- Way better at it.
The game became easier for me.
- So let's talk about it.
Does that mean you chose a
path that gave you confidence,
could lead to financial and
professional success?
- [Allen] For sure, for sure.
- Over what probably, it's pretty obvious,
especially in the last 48
hours I've been with you,
basketball was a bigger love.
- For sure, but I think that
once I started my senior year,
when I started to dive in.
'Cause I had a really good
senior year in basketball,
but once I started to dive in to football,
and really put my mind there,
going into my senior year.
For me, I was all in it, you know?
- [Allen] Got it.
- I still have a weird love for it.
But I don't know.
It was just different when
it came to like football,
you know what I'm saying?
When I would step on the field,
just my craft, and how I would perfect it.
- [Gary] You just knew.
- It was a lot different,
it was a lot different.
- Interesting.
- It's so different that
it's hard to explain.
I tell people all the time.
I never, I don't remember the last time
I actually picked up
a basketball or played
five on five or something,
just 'cause my passion
and my love for the game
is so high, so intense,
you know what I'm saying?
I wouldn't even want to put myself,
let's go to the rec and play five on five.
'Cause I may not leave.
- I get that.
It's almost how I think about meditation.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- I don't want to meditate,
'cause I'm so happy with my mental state.
I almost weirdly understand
what you just said.
- So it's like.
- The normal person kind of hears that,
like you don't even want to play a random
basketball game 'cause you
know you might get in it.
- Exactly, you know how
people talk about Jordan,
and they joke about Jordan,
they say like Michael
Jordan had these card games,
he wouldn't let the person leave.
They'll be there for like-
- Yeah, 21.
- That's how I feel about
basketball, so it's like-
- I have a great Jets-Bears story.
I told it the other day,
I think you guys heard it.
My best friend Brandon
was a Cubs fan, baseball.
And we had baseball cards together.
- [Allen] Mhmm.
- And he came over one night to sleep over
the night before a baseball card show,
and we played Madden.
And he took the Bears,
he didn't give a fuck
about the Bears.
He was Chicago, 'cause he was Cubs.
And some miraculous way he beat me
after I like destroyed
him every other time.
And I wouldn't let him go to sleep.
It was like midnight.
And I wouldn't let him go to
sleep until we re-matched.
And then I could tell he was bullshitting,
'cause he was mad that I
was forcing him to play.
So he was like not trying.
But then I countered it
with like making pretend
he was trying and blew him
out like 72 to nothing.
And was like in his face at like 2:00 a.m.
- [Allen] Exactly.
- Exactly.
- And it's crazy because
the last kind of serious
that I played, was an intramural.
Not intramural, but basketball
class at Penn State.
We had a basketball class.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And I played like my sophomore year.
I used to be so intense.
I remember playing in the game
scoring like 60, 70 points.
- And everyone's like, yo chill.
Yo they used to call me a gym class hero.
'Cause in gym class in high
school, I would go hard.
I'm trying to find my report card.
My report card, look at this Allen.
This is my high school report card.
I got all Ds and Fs on some real shit.
In freshman, sophomore, these
are literally my grades.
This is my report card.
But if you notice, only four
As in high school history.
Freshman, sophomore,
junior, and senior year gym.
- Where's, health too huh.
- Yeah, bro you don't understand how much
I checked the fuck out.
I would go into class and
read the baseball card guide
and the wine spectator, sell
and sling candy and cards,
and just make money and be out.
- I got suspended for
that early on in school.
Slinging candy.
- I love it.
- Okay thank you so much brother.
- [Caller] Thank you so much.
I mean, I'm gonna have friends
that can't believe I talk to Gary V.,
and I'm gonna have
friends who can't believe
I talked to Allen Robinson.
- It's a good day bro.
- [Caller] A dream moment.
- Thank you brother.
Take care bro.
- [Caller] Thank you.
- Let's get one more in.
Allen, anything before we get
further along and wrap up?
Anything you want to talk about?
Anything on your mind?
Anything you're passionate
about, anything cool?
- That's a good question.
You know, for me, I'm
passionate about a lot.
Actually, I'm kind of, it's
been a work in progress
but I actually have
some samples and stuff.
I had a wave where I
was making swim trunks.
- That's interesting.
- Yeah, this is the thing.
Me and my buddies, we would like hang out,
but if you ever go to like a pool party
or something like that,
like you gotta wear swim trunks.
Especially if it's like
in Vegas or something.
- [Gary] Of course.
- But when you go to the normal
store to get swim trunks,
all of them have like sunsets.
- Like flamingos and shit.
- Like everything that
nobody wants to wear.
So I'm like damn, there's
no fashionable swim trunks.
So I was like, you know what,
I'm gonna just start making some.
Even, all my swim trunks,
even like my buddies and stuff wear,
are all the ones that I made.
- Get out.
- I'm dead serious.
- Is there a way to see them
anywhere like a website?
- I don't, I just have samples right now.
Right now, I'm starting the process.
'Cause that's the thing,
when you get into clothing,
clothing is unreasonably expensive.
You know what I'm saying, for some reason.
So over the years, you
know what I'm saying,
I'm making samples, making designs,
you know what I'm saying.
- So what does your shit look like?
- Um, let me see, let me see if I got.
- Well there's people listening.
- I got like camo,
different kind of camos.
Plaids, checkerboards.
- [Gary] Yup.
- You know what I'm saying,
anything that you would
kind of say that's like-
- Anything that doesn't have a dolphin.
- Yeah, they're just more fashionable.
Something that you could actually,
you could probably just wear as shorts,
you know what I'm saying?
But they're swim trunks.
- I've always thought that,
I have the concept of going somewhere
where I know I have to
go into swim trunks,
where I would only wear
swim trunks all day
'cause I'm too lazy to switch.
- [Allen] Mhmm.
- And was like, they need
to do something with this.
- And that's the thing.
That's kind of what I was making.
Like I said before.
The swim trunks that I make,
you know what I'm saying,
or that I'll make in the future,
are swim trunks that
you're not just wearing
them just because, like oh I
gotta get some swim trunks,
so let me go to Dick's
Sporting Goods or something.
(Gary laughs)
- Shout out to Dick's.
- Sunset surf, you know what I'm saying.
This person's surfing on my swim trunks.
(Gary laughs)
Like damn, I just want some
swim trunks that look cool, man.
- I love that.
- Can I get some camo,
actually a decent fashion.
I actually love camo, I'm not gonna lie.
- I see it, it looks hot.
That's funny.
(phone rings)
Who's this?
- [Crew member] Wayne Wool.
- [Gary] Wayne, Wayne?
- [Wayne] Hello.
- [Gary] Wayne Wool.
- [Wayne] Aw man yeah,
what's going on man?
- Life's good man, say what's up to Allen.
- Yo what's good.
- [Wayne] Allen, what's going on brother?
Look, man, it's crazy that
I actually got through.
I'm actually from Huntsville, Alabama.
So I'm about an hour
outside of Chattanooga.
- That's what's up.
- I'm actually familiar
with The Sasha Group,
I grew up in Chat with Mickey,
so I just want to say
thanks for having me on.
- So happy to have you bro, what's good?
- I really wanted to know,
I'm a former linebacker,
a former player, and I really wanted
to ask a question to Allen.
I have a young daughter,
we're gonna have a son one day,
how do you introduce manhood, that concept
of what it means to be a man to a kid,
without emphasizing money,
emphasizing what it means
to like make money?
Then you talk about getting
like empathy, kindness,
understanding, both things.
How do you actually teach that to your,
as a professional athlete
where a lot of things
are thrown at you, how do you
have a presence to teach
how to be a good man?
- Bro, that's a great,
bro, thank you so much
for asking that question.
Go ahead Allen.
- Honestly, I would just say it comes down
to just like the moral
compass of everything.
I think if, you kind of set
the morals of everything,
I think that's what people live by.
'Cause again, growing
up, my dad and my family,
you know, we didn't have a ton of money
or anything like that.
But you know, everything that
my dad just instilled in me
in general, ultimately translated to me
to be able to have some success.
You know, we didn't talk about,
we'd be like yeah it'd be cool for you
to get to the NFL and be rich.
You know what I'm saying, this
is what hard work gets you.
This is what dedication gets you.
This is what being able to fight
through adversity gets you.
- [Wayne] Yeah.
- And it's able for you
to, to balance your life,
you know, to push through
a lot of different things.
That's the thing, I
mean, people go through
a lot of different situations,
you know what I'm saying.
But at the end of the
day, if you know your goal
and you know what it
takes to get to your goal
and you have the morals
to be able to get there,
then you'll be able to get there.
- [Gary] Mhmm.
- You know and everything else will kinda
figure itself out.
- What's really question
about your question bro
is that, the fact that
you're even asking it
and using words like kindness and empathy,
like you don't even know the emotion
that's running through
my body right now, bro.
How old are you?
- [Gary] I'm 31 dude.
- Man, you don't even know.
Obviously 'cause you know The Sasha Group
which is the office we
have in Chattanooga,
and Mickey, and you're calling,
so obviously you know a lot about me.
- I know everything about you Gary.
My social media's the therapist,
but everything that I do
is about transparency
and about understanding
how do you actually get to the bottom line
without sacrificing yourself.
That was really my biggest thing.
I played football in college.
I thought I was going to the NFL.
Shit didn't happen, so I had to say
how do I get to the end goal without,
just going a different path?
- Even, I tell people all the time.
Even from what you're saying right now,
listening to you talk,
you may not ultimately got to the NFL,
but where you got to mentally.
- [Gary] It's crazy.
- It's a lot further than anybody else
would have been able to get to.
I don't know if football did that for you.
- Parenting, neighborhood,
hitting rock bottom.
Let me say this.
- [Wayne] I appreciate it.
- Bro, it's true though.
You've already won
because your perspective
for the question, is a winning question.
- [Allen] Exactly.
- You already know the
answer that you asked
because you know that I and
others and now more of us
are starting to educate the culture,
that fuck money, look for happiness.
- [Allen] Exactly, exactly.
- And of course, when
people look at me and Allen,
they're like, "Easy for you to say."
But they don't know who we were pre-money.
- [CWayne] Exactly.
- They don't know how happy
we were in our process.
- And there's a lot of people who have,
there's a lot of people who have money
that you see go through
a lot of crazy shit,
you know what I'm saying.
At the end of the day,
you see a lot of people
who don't have that much money
who are the happiest people.
You know, you can't even
correlate, you know,
the manhood, the kindness, and all that
to money, it's all morals in itself.
And then whatever comes from
that is gonna be success.
- And bro, what's real interesting
is, you have a daughter,
and you said, I'm looking to have a son.
And you know, I understand guy culture.
I also first had a daughter.
You know, what's real interesting.
- I love, actually, I'm a proud.
- I'm sure you are.
I'm sure you are.
- [Wayne] The thing that
terrifies me is knowing
that my son is gonna watch what I do.
Your daughter will listen to you,
my daughter is the most
emotionally intelligent
five year old in the world,
but my son is gonna say
"well fuck all that."
- Let me give you a little
bit of knowledge right here,
your daughter's gonna watch
everything you're doing too.
You wanna get really terrified?
The way you interact with your daughter
is gonna be the fundamental framework
of how she chooses the
person she wants to be with
for the rest of her life.
Whether that's leaning
into somebody like her dad,
or running away from
somebody like their dad.
So they're all watching,
let's start there.
They're all watching.
Number two, number two.
This is over, you already won.
Allen nailed it.
I was just watching Allen, I was like
Allen needs to have his own show.
Allen picked up on exactly the game,
'cause Allen is the
byproduct of great parenting
and so am I.
And the fact that you care.
Once you turn that fear, which
I'm not even sure is fear,
I would argue that you
used the word terrified,
and you A. may be terrified,
or B. You're just being thoughtful.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- And I appreciate that.
- And I'll say as well, even for me
when I think about having a son,
it's not terrifying in a sense.
But you know, when you have a girl,
you can just be a loving dad.
But at the end of the day, having a boy,
you know what I'm
saying, especially being,
I don't know about you,
but especially being
African American, there's a lot of things
that you have to, there's
a lot of pressures
that you put on your son
before you even have a son.
- [Gary] Of course.
- Because you wanna know how to mold them
to a lot of different things.
And I definitely do understand it,
'cause I can for sure attest to it
when I think about having a son.
It's like damn, I want to be a loving dad
but I don't want to have
too much tough love.
I don't want to have too much of this,
too much of that.
I want to be an empathetic dad but I also
want to prepare him for the real world.
- Here's real life, as the
dad of a seven year old.
You two are gonna have lots
of plans and lots of theories
and then it's gonna be Mike Tyson shit.
It's really nice that you boys have plans,
and then you're gonna have one,
and their personality and
their DNA is gonna emerge.
- [Allen] Gotcha.
- I had lots of thoughts
about my little guy
and a lot of things are like I thought,
and a lot of things
are not like I thought.
- [Wayne] Mhmm.
- And now, it's round five and I've been
punched in the face a whole bunch,
and do I have the ability to adjust?
Am I Buster Douglas?
Or am I Tony Tucker?
So like, you gotta figure that out.
- [Allen] For sure.
- [Wayne] Gotcha, gotcha.
- By the way, Tony Tucker reference
is a real nerdy 1980s boxing reference
which is Tony Tucker was
the boxer that made me think
Mike Tyson was vulnerable
because he fought him
quite well, and then the next fight
he lost to Buster Douglas.
For all you boxing
heads, that was for you.
- [Wayne] Gotcha.
I appreciate you Gary,
Allen, man, love to you all.
- [Allen] Appreciate you man.
- Take care of yourself.
This is what gets me fired up about life.
Like that phone call just
inspired the fuck outta me.
- [Allen] Yeah, me too.
- I feel it, I feel it.
- I even say that all the time,
as far as, there's a lot
of expectations again,
that you may put on a son or whatever
because it's like, I mean,
you have those expectations,
and it comes from a selfish
sense of, a little bit.
But it's you only want the best,
but at the end of the day you gotta
take a step back and say.
- It comes from a selfish place.
- [Allen] For sure.
- And the only way to be a great parent
is to be selfless.
And you know this, you grew up in sports.
All those delusional parents
that are ragging their
kids into the ground,
who have no shot of ever
being in the league,
these parents are delusional.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- And it's selfish.
They wanna feel good at the country club
and say their boy dropped 39.
It's fucked up.
- [Allen] I agree.
- School, sports, looks, accomplishments.
People aren't reverse engineering
their kids for happiness.
They're engineering them
to make them look good.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- Parents stop fucking up.
- [Allen] That's what's up.
- Fuck you, on some real shit, fuck you.
You should not be using your kids
as a tool to make you look good.
And that happens in
African American culture.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- In Russian immigrant culture,
in Asian immigrant culture,
in Indian immigrant culture.
Every subset, and even in fifth generation
American white, there's
plenty of that too.
We need to stop.
- [Allen] I agree.
- Our children are not
trophies representing us.
Our children are human beings that we are
supposed to be molding, and
that requires us to listen,
while molding with good decision-making.
Not listen when eighth grade
Allen's like, "I ain't going."
No, you're molding there.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- That's 'cause they saw
the passion of sport,
and ambition and competition.
They were molding.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- If they didn't, but they
thought that you'd be 6'3"
and could catch everything
but you wanted to dance,
and they made you play football,
that's fucked up.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- You got it, that's the difference.
- [Allen] That makes sense.
- If you see a kid who's
not good at school,
Indian immigrant parent, she doesn't need
to be a fucking doctor or engineer, relax.
- [Allen] Yeah.
- There are other ways to win.
I know why you want them to
be an engineer or a doctor,
Asian, Indian, Russian parent,
it's cause it looks good to
your parent or to your sister.
But it's fucking up your kid
who's gonna resent you for life, stop it.
- [Allen] I agree.
- I know you do, I've been listening.
- I agree.
- So does every other
person that had the miracle,
let's call it what it is, the luck,
of being the by-product of their parents.
That's who you and I are.
Shit matters, give me good parents
and a rough situation like you and I had,
and I'll show you superstars.
- Yeah, for sure.
- The end.
That's all set up.
Allen, thank you so much.
- [Allen] No problem man,
thanks for having me.
- Where can people find you?
- You can find me on
Instagram, Allen Robinson 12.
Or you can find me on Twitter,
same, Allen Robinson 12.
- Talk to me about 12.
Eight was college?
- Eight was college, 15 was
Jacksonville, 12 was Chicago.
For me, I'm a person whereas,
nah, I like to, when I take on new stuff,
you know what I'm saying.
- You want new numbers?
- Yeah, I want a whole new thing.
- What was your high school number?
- My sophomore year it was,
no my junior year was 32.
And my senior year was one.
Both basketball and football.
Football my junior year was 14.
- All different numbers
all over the place.
- And then college, I
was eight throughout.
And then Jacksonville, I was 15 throughout
until I got to Chicago.
- [Gary] 12.
- Yeah.
- Thank you bro.
- Appreciate you having me man.
(instrumental jazz)